[Musique]
sa réputation dépasse les frontières du
québec produits du terroir confectionnés
avec soin qui fait notre fierté mais une
grande partie de notre sirop d'érable
même celui qui est certifiée bio
polluent l'atmosphère brûle du pétrole
pour faire un produit biologique c'est
un non sens un peu si on mettrait sinon
on risquait de sirop fait avec vue
pétrole brûlé à 100% je pense que ce
serait pas vendeur
environ la moitié de tous le sirop
d'érable produit dans la province et
bouillie dans des évaporateurs qui
fonctionne au mazout pour produire 10
litres de sirop il faut en moyenne 6
litres de carburant situé fait à l'huile
taux de sucre est la plus grosse
empreinte carbone au monde est situé
fête au bois ou électriques toit le
sucre que la plus petite empreinte
carbone au monde au total l'industrie
acéricole rejette plus de 30 mille
tonnes de gaz à effet de serre chaque
année au québec
georges fois moins de conscience sociale
tout pourquoi produire dire on va s'en
aller vers les voitures électriques puis
on veut produire du sirop d'érable avec
dumas je m'en donner ça c'était pas la
route roberto landry va mettre au
rancart ces deux évaporateur au mazout
après la saison des sucres l'an prochain
c'est un appareil alimenté par des
granules de bois donc beaucoup moins
polluant qui prendra leur place un silo
contenant les granules devrait aussi
être installés fadeeva prater qui va se
monter autour de 200 mille places mais
en retour la série culte heures verra sa
facture énergétique baisser alors que le
prix du mazout a explosé un père 188
chez plus de l'ordre autour de 50%
convoi chauve et en coûts d'énergie et
en plus il pourra obtenir une subvention
de 100 mille dollars de transition
énergétique québec si le montant maximal
prévu dans le programme destiné à
réduire les gaz à effet de serre dans le
secteur acéricole
même scénario pour pierre rue caron qui
va lui aussi passer à un évaporateur aux
granules de bois un évaporateur ça sort
à peu près 15 à 20 ans je me voyais
pauvres rully du mazout encore 15 ans
déclare une source d'énergie qui est
dépassé les acériculteurs peuvent aussi
se tourner vers des appareils
électriques six cafés yvon tremblay il
ya neuf ans il ne reviendrait pas en
arrière c'est facile d'opération c'est
vraiment informatisé à marc p c'est pas
dur bouillir avec sa c5 fou et moins
dispendieux on sauve aux normes à plat
des devins miltiade few que consommer je
consomme à environ 4000 pierre
d'électricité mais la conversion se fait
plutôt lentement ou cours des cinq
dernières années le sirop d'érable
fabriqués dans des évaporateurs au
mazout est passé de 52 à 47 % de la
production totale bien souvent quand tu
es tout installé à l'huile l'huile c'est
simple d'utilisation c'est la peur du
changement qui fait la jacques boucher
accompagne des acériculteurs qui veulent
remplacer leur évaporateur selon lui les
réticences mon finir par s'estomper
on est habitués avec notre système qui
boxe avons su bien marché que seulement
portée comme problème on va attendre que
le voisin effet si ça marche bien je
veux le faire avec l'augmentation du
pétrole qu'on connaît cette année je
convaincu cet été il en a beaucoup qui
m'ont mais y réfléchir s'apprête au
beurre
une masse maintenant pour diriger les
vrais vers d'autres choses
selon roberto landry les producteurs
doivent absolument effectuer un virage
vert s'est imposé que les règles projet
avec dumas je sais pas des bons
producteurs locaux chaud non plus là
mais la consommateurs vos flèches dirigé
qu'est ce qu'elle touche amateurs veut
ça ajoute de la noblesse à notre produit
deux de peau brûlée du pétrole
[Musique]
l'industrie acéricole veut réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 20
9% d'ici 2030 mais si elle veut y
parvenir de nombreux producteurs devront
suivre l'exemple de roberto landry et de
pierre leca rend ici olivier bâche un
réseau canada dans le témiscouata
[Musique]